in America's election headquarters
tonight a new call for social justice
from a Democratic freshman lawmaker is
being supported tonight by one of the
leading Democratic presidential hopefuls
of course when a Kristen Fisher tells us
what's in the proposal and why this top
candidate is backing it first it was
Medicare for all then the green New Deal
now congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez is putting her weight behind a
new plan to fight poverty the plan calls
for capping annual rent increases
pressuring federal contractors to offer
better wages and benefits updating the
national poverty guidelines to take into
account access to health insurance
childcare and new necessities like
internet access and allowing
undocumented immigrants to have full
access to social welfare programs just
society embraces 2020 contender senator
Elizabeth Warren was quick to announce
her support of the plan by saying quote
it's going to take big structural change
to tackle poverty and inequality in the
US and AOC suggests society is just the
type of bold comprehensive thinking
we'll need to get it done as Warren
surges in the polls so does the
possibility of her proposal to break up
big tech Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg
was caught on tape telling employees
that he would likely have no choice but
to sue the US government if Warren wins
Warren responded by saying what would
really suck is if we don't fix a corrupt
system that lets giant companies like
Facebook engage in illegal
anti-competitive practices warns rise
has come at senator Bernie Sanders his
expense as the to fight for support from
the far left
but today Sanders released his first TV
ad of 2020 and massive fundraising
numbers over the last three months his
campaign raked in more than 25 million
dollars since July the biggest quarter
yet from a 2020 Democrat mayor Pete
Budaj edge also had an impressive third
quarter Hall after a summer spent
languishing in the single digits of most
polls his campaign took in about 19
million
for the quarter cementing mayor Pete's
place in the top tier but the Trump
campaign wins the day it just announced
a presidential fundraising record along
with the Republican National Committee
it raised a hundred and twenty five
million dollars over the last three
months and to put that in perspective
former President Obama and the DNC
raised about seventy million over the
same period eight years ago but it's a
big haul Kristen thank you